what is up there reject nation greg and
john here today we are going to watch
brooklyn nine nine one by sixteen the
party party time guys subscribe and
click that bell to get notified when our
next b99 reaction is up hit that like
button if you haven't enjoyed this video
full length watch along where you stick
up with the time code over at our
patreon page cover a whole bunch of
dealios over there
last but not least pratham jindal thanks
for writing down these highlights for us
bud no b9i could be a fascinating edit
and i think you always do a stellar job
let's get to it
[Music]
everyone check your email kevin kosner
requests your presence at raymond's
birthday party is he the star of dances
with wolves
he's captain holt's husband oh hell yeah
oh damn i can't wait to see the inside
of raymond's house i bet it's really
fancy
no it's probably just an empty white
cube with a usb port in it for him to
plug his finger in when he's on sleep
mode
my husband kevin has invited you all to
my party there's very little street
parking no gifts no singing of happy
birthday
his husband invited us not him it was
kind of a last-minute invite because he
thinks we're going to embarrass him in
front of his husband which frankly is
insulting oh man all the orange soda
spilled out of my cereal
happy birthday you sly old fox say some
charm for the party oh you mean the
party that you begrudgingly invited us
to at the last minute cause you don't
want us there i couldn't be happier you
coming and it shows
i'm not sure you and kevin will get
along
in fact i will guarantee you that by the
end of the night kev and i will be best
friends he hates being called kevin or
does he yes
my secret weapon for winning over kevin
in this box is every grizzly crime the
99 has worked in the past eight years
also i've loaded all of my favorite
karaoke backing tracks onto my phone
kevin and i will be duetting rolling in
the deep that's it
[Music]
sergeant i believe they're called orgies
no look five
nice everyone here needs some
instruction on interacting with
grown-ups sergeant why am i here i'm
always incredibly appropriate in high
school i was voted most appropriate ooh
self burn those are rare
no staring at your phones no rolling in
two hours late no sweatpants no jeans
and no shorts why are there so many
rules i mean next thing you're gonna say
is we can't be late yeah that's like the
first thing i said
this neighborhood's amazing class just
seeps at it they look great team cleans
up well i specifically said no shorts
serge it's not my fault you said so many
things about shorts i got confused oh
peralta where have you been oh no sorry
i know i am 3t 5 minutes
hey buddy hey watson you want to watch
brooklyn
finest bottle of wine please that will
be sixteen hundred dollars great i'd
like your eight dollarist bottle
oh no
[Laughter]
detectives meet my husband
kevin
oh and look he brought us some wine
this is legally called wine drink
oh
you know i worked a double homicide on
this block a couple years ago yes i'm
sorry perhaps raymond didn't say
anything our home has a no shop talk
policy oh i don't bring home beowulf and
he doesn't bring home cough stories
was he an actor
so kevin i hear you're a professor at
columbia that's right yes i had the
classics department oh interesting
classics zeppelin hendrix die hard total
classics head over here
i'm joking obviously
the odyssey and
the one you said when we got here the
wolf won
don't we go mingle and let the detective
settle in
oh no ah what happened to your shirt i
spilled a wonderful winter salsa
where's your party bib boyle
boyle take my sweater
ah
it fits really well i have similar
physiques we've been here all in four
minutes and you guys have already
forgotten everything i said
party huddle stop
[Laughter]
the shorts
charles you know everything about food
that's all you talk about i mean i don't
think anyone will ever know everything
scully opera hitch guy talk about
nothing
got it make sure she doesn't say
anything insane or steal anything too
late what's your cultural specialty easy
kevin mentioned the new yorker and i've
totally read that
keep a low profile chuckle anecdotes try
not to start any conversations got it
wait a minute
you're hitchcocking me well not
surprising we're practically twins
we're gonna do that sometime
don't move as a group you're not
gazelles
they're watching this
no no i said millimeter
you're too funny great humor words
raymond you know reminds me
oh boy oh no
the one written by david remnick i love
that piece from four weeks ago or was it
three weeks no
four
smooth
i could talk about that article for
hours right it's unnecessary let's do
that right now let's do there they are
kevin let's greet our guests to be
continued can't wait well we got to find
that magazine it's gotta be in here
somewhere right this place is like a
candy store for nerds oh no
oh no
ah
pepper relish on your arancini cut
through the richness add a little levity
you really know your food you could say
it's the only thing i'm allowed to talk
about
i'm vivian ludley i work with kevin
author of stone fruits and stone stones
foot of the paleolithic era i'm a huge
fan
it's got the best recipes for making
salads out of moss
oh yeah i want one
carl's gonna get lucky tonight
we both have blue hand towels we have
the same microwave and once i buy
coasters made out of geodes we'll both
have those
it's a birthday party not a recon
mission you can get this back at the end
of the night oh man
it's black tom selleck and white sydney
poetier nice
[Laughter]
crappy library's full of books a crap
library all of the magazines are in the
bathroom ah
crap library
i didn't hear you silently sneak up on
me oh that reminds me tell kevin that i
am available for brunch on sunday the
17th why are you talking about the new
yorker all of a sudden i always talk
about smart stuff the jazz age
50s movies or from the 50s those were
the categories on jeopardy last night
don't try so hard to impress my husband
yes sir to the crap library
[Laughter]
may 2nd
come on
uh just a second
i'm halfway done with what's happening
in here okay
what the hell
yes
the sun gets to me every time it's
beautiful how long have you two been
together we've been partners for almost
30 years
harassed at work harassed
for what for being a gay couple who
works together in the nypd
[Laughter]
hang up that phone i'm talking to my
credit card company i tried to get an
online subscription to the new yorker
apparently based on my previous
purchases they assumed it was fraud it's
crazy i'm fancy one time i had coffee
flavored ice cream shut up
if you're not desperate the first two
paragraphs of the article are on the
free site
you have one minute to look it up and
then if i catch you on that phone again
oh
you just broke your own phone yeah my
babies are on a cloud
[Laughter]
lovely party kevin these tiny pickles
are hilarious
they're called corny
about human trafficking we were
discussing yes so interesting especially
the first two paragraphs right but what
do you think of the thesis vis-a-vis
modern slavery and its undeniable role
in the economy
good
and if you ask me the whole thesis was
way off base vis-a-vis the rest of the
article vis-a-vis america
the article was anti-slavery are you
saying that slavery is good you know i
think you're missing the point of the
article you must not be remembering it
right well i just read it last night as
i got in bed it's quite fresh in my
memory
fortunately i have got to hit the crap
library excuse me one second
how were you single
you're not seeing anyone
no
there's nobody in my life go forward go
forth sort of a sad thing to wink about
i realize now
i can't believe i'm frenching in the
closet i feel like a teenager chewing
this [ __ ] leaf
it'll give our kissing umami flavor
[Laughter]
[Music]
delicious
kinky
time to put my newfound knowledge to the
test
oh no
so sir popcorn setting always too short
am i right
i'm sorry
if you'll excuse me yeah
i thought i had done enough recon but
clearly i've only scratched the surface
i have to massively violate his privacy
and i've always considered movies a
writer's meeting i can't agree it's
gedard's film
come on
i mean truffaut is also important sir oh
no hold this i got to go
[Laughter]
maybe it is truffaut's film
tell me the captain's secrets unveil
yourself to me
oh how it's made contact lenses
bingo
bones more fox programming what are you
doing here i need to find a new yorker
that kept left by the bed so i can
justify this whole pro-slavery stance
oh
my god
i cannot believe you would both violate
the please stay downstairs which was
permanently posted
get out of here i don't know why we have
to have the uh what do we do
crap library go why are you upset with
me your employees are the ones putting a
damper on the party they are acting
terribly you're the one who's been
acting terribly tonight you've been
cured and snobby with my guests you've
been needling poor peralta so much you
practically made him a new suit
even when we're fighting you're
hilarious stop it
dog allergies
grab the dog
you know what i knew this wasn't going
to work it never has we should have just
gone out for dinner to a restaurant like
we do every year why did you make me
invite them i made you invite them
because i like them they're good people
oh
santiago are you hiding in my bathroom
no no no
no
no
occupied
[ __ ] no
my computer bag got a hole in the bottom
and my power cord fell out
last night was such a disaster
we could have been really cool people we
weren't but we could have been well as
soon as he unveiled his no cop talk
policy i was sunk well he spent the last
30 years with a cop maybe sick of
hearing about it maybe that's not what
he's sick of santiago you brilliant
bastard you figured it out
i'd like to tell you about a case i
solved your friends immediately asked
hitchcock and scully if they were
harassed and there was something
interesting about that photo in your
library you and the captain were shunted
off to the side i think you dislike cops
raymond has been put through hell by his
colleagues look exactly like you
devastatingly handsome
i'm sorry i'm uncomfortable with
emotions
i'd like to make it up to you captain
thank you for joining us a proper
birthday dinner amy chose the restaurant
oh perfect i've always wanted to come
here
boyle picked the menu vivian helped oh
oh it's great
tell you about your party sir i tried to
keep them in line but i failed well
that's not your job i'm only sorry you
didn't get a chance to enjoy yourself
gina has brought back all the silverware
that she stole from your house
oh my god
also this clock
no
this isn't ours and my contribution will
be to refrain from discussing the new
yorker for the rest of my living days
thank you jake you're welcome kevin call
me kev
oh he told you to say that didn't he
well you are always playing pranks on me
raymond just once let me be the funny
one
[Laughter]
oh awesome
[Music]
this part always gets me
get that shirt off hitchcock
oh that's sweet oh yeah
that was really sweet that was a delight
they even managed to turn an episode
into being a case to solve
that is not a case to begin with
no actual official police work
whatsoever this episode managed to make
being a detective pan out for the best
i like the setups the only cliche was
eavesdropping in the bathroom yeah that
was about it and all these sitcoms
oh that's a classic it's a requisite you
have to have an ease dropping from the
bathroom moment at some point but it
works here
because
that bathroom was way off limits yes
versus most sitcoms where it's
just the bathroom let me over here
something conveniently placed outside
this door versus let me hear something
that they came in here for confidence to
say in the first place yeah um but
yeah you know that's that that is a
fascinating thing to include here about
you know like you have the whole history
here that's within the show of holt
being gay and the struggles he's had
with being gay
holt is gay he's been gay
uh
and i
i
i forget about um
the the
the pat the history of not that i like
forget about it it's just
i'm such an amazing person that i'm not
bothered at all by homosexuality
and i want to congratulate
myself from
both of us we're both not homophobes
aren't we amazing human beings i think
we should be awarded or rewarded for
that finding it's so normal doing the
bare minimum you should be lauded that's
amazing right
but
yeah i know with the
with the with that part it's
it's actually kind of staring you right
in the face the whole time
and you it's it's something that just
makes perfect sense why the kevin
character
would ultimately not
like like it's such a like a great
scripted reason as to why he wouldn't
like cops like it's not something about
their relationship necessarily it's not
about uh
the way how like oh way raymond is at
work or something like that it all has
to do with the way how cops generally
have been in like in his life for the
cop that he fell in love with and i
thought that was such like a a really
cool
way to have this feel well justified
because the whole time i am watching it
going like what's this dude's problem
yeah this is a dick
just a snobby [ __ ] why would hope be
with this guy yeah because it's like
they play it up of oh you're like the
sophisticated
well imbued
knowledgeable
professor affluent new yorker yeah and
and so you think it has more to do with
that yeah and looking down on someone
lesser than yeah yeah and come to find
out it has nothing to do with that yeah
that it's all about that treatment of it
and also the rev and i like that idea of
two of like oh it was actually whole two
is the one who encouraged them the way
they set it up is like
hold they didn't want them
or raymond didn't want them kevin wanted
them
um and then you get there it's like oh
kevin seems like he really doesn't want
them yeah then you find out that raymond
just wanted
wanted them there but he wanted it to
seem like kevin was the one who wanted
them yeah they wanted to have that like
ice breaker built in yeah but it's not
really panning out so i thought that was
a really great moment at the at the very
end there how are all like tied together
from solving a case to get to have the
intimate dinner that they were talking
about having
when uh they were eavesdropping on them
yeah but yeah the party scene itself was
hilarious that was really funny because
yeah that was that was too funny yeah it
was like an obstacle course of character
comedy you know getting a great
opportunity to split everybody up well
to get a group reaction to just everyone
meeting kevin and you know feeling out
the dynamic preparing for the party but
then yeah having everybody get to spread
out and
go with their one mandated field of
expertise just yeah led to so many great
character bits perhaps my favorite ever
gina bit to date yeah with all the
psychologists and stuff that was
hilarious and like yeah the different
kind of people that populated the party
too just like expanding on like these
definitely seem like the kinds of people
holt and or raymond and kevin might
consort with and also who would find
raymond hilarious because they are all
so dry
uh and then yeah like this is really
exemplary of there is of like what makes
the show so great is like i feel like
this is one another one of those
episodes that's like it's got some
really funny broad character comedy but
it comes back around to everybody wins
at the end and everybody gets like a
moment to you know
do the right thing or have sort of a
sentimental growth of some kind like
even scully you know gets to put one of
his actual skills to good use which is
just such a nice little nugget uh and
yeah like the way like amy picks the
restaurant and boyle helps with the menu
and everything and and even just the
little thing about like man i'm just
sorry terry didn't get to enjoy the
party because he was looking after all
you guys like the rascally family that
they are really shines out in an episode
like this
and uh great sight gag in the bathroom
in the crap library
she didn't bring a boil i didn't bring a
boil he totally hooked up
with an older woman and found what i
assume can only be lasting love with a
character who's going to become a series
regular yeah
yeah i think he hit them
hit the nail on the head right there
excited to see her apply it on the money
man
undoubtedly that is what is happening
yeah
most definitely
the only character that didn't seem to
get
as much like silly or like i don't know
as many bits to do was rosa like i
thought it was funny that rose's whole
job is just to
keep gina in line and i enjoyed her
presence in the episode all i didn't
feel like she had like that much to do
as compared to maybe a lot of the other
cast
i think she looked great she looked
incredible she didn't have to do
anything else
all right she just got to to be
a presence she just got to be looking
damn fine
that's right
that's right with that intimidating skit
stare
makes you look good in that dress
it's good to find her very good just
keeps happening
it's okay it's okay i'm here for you
all right
santiago bit was kind of funny with
wanting to satisfy that's so cringe oh
yeah i like cringy humor a lot she she's
got great cringe comedy
a whole hummus thing and and the like
investigative little nuggets that lead
to that
well
my favorite little bit is actually how
holt is really hilarious outside of the
precinct even though he's not really any
different yeah he's got a tad bit more
of a subtle smile to his demeanor
but
he's like people are always like
you're the funny one you're hilarious
stop cracking jokes even in an art
yeah like the pinnacle of that joke like
the best little like button to put on
that i love how like andy zambra just so
like so baffled by like how everyone
finds them so funny yeah yeah and i love
the the tie around with the let me be
the funny one for once call me kev thing
because that i truly did not see coming
that's such a great like it's so it's
such a simple joke but when he says it
and and he like you know for as perfect
as as you know it's
i feel like any time you talk about
brooklyn nine-nine you just start
heaping praise on andre brower because
that's one of the things to do but i
thought he matched him really well and
i'm excited to i would i gotta imagine
we will see more kevin in the future so
i'm excited to see what comes of that
and you know what
comedy comes of that character further
down the line that's very true
all right guys
well this was a this is a great episode
another another really solid one isn't
that exciting just me kevin yeah
gotta meet terry's family
characters who i thought we would never
meet i thought it was always going to be
like a running gag that you never meet
that offscreen yeah but there's like but
it's always developing
but you never see them i thought i
really thought that's what the show was
doing it was like oh you're always going
to hear about updates and what's going
on but you're never actually going to
see them yeah they're just going to use
like the the build in your mind but
i think
from introducing terry's family from
introducing uh kevin here
that it hasn't disappointed at all yeah
and it's only elevated the show just
imagine pretty soon we'll we'll meet
boyle's ex-wife and new boyfriend who he
lives with right right at this point i'm
like the possibilities seem endless
all right guys so leave your thoughts
down below just go ahead hit that
subscribe button hit that bell
hit that like button let's shout out
some patrons who have been showing their
awesome support to us
don't drown aqua attic o5 oh chris
lawson follow the rules there's a bear
in the garage rosalie taylor my suit
pants are really tight ryan gosling
rosenthal pleasure to meet you gail
craig ferguson j ron warner what is it
what when and what
what does that mean here's my money
stacks the crook don't jump off that
cliff rodriguez see what i did chris
busting makes me feel good mr crispy
have them have them donuts aaron meyers
you're like mike myers
relation danny all you can eat pancakes
what's going on buddy alex beaver damn
kathleen mayer not to be mistaken with
bill maher pseudonymous and titty all of
branchdale guy i know what your name
means differently
sane levity
levitt oh you just bring so much levity
josh barnes where they keep the hay
bales and stuff so see how we mixed it
up i hope you enjoyed those wonderfully
clever and witty say we mix it up
twist throw in a curve ball yeah
creative juices
look out thanks for being part of our
page love you guys and all your support
and uh keep on keeping on as long as
that means that you you're here with us
love you
each individual oh my god end the video
[Music]